[Music]
if you've bought any sneakers recently
they may not be the real deal
like Nike Nike 3 and 95. exactly the
same Footwear accounts for about 20 of
the value of all counterfeit Goods in a
global market worth over 500 billion
dollars and Rising
the quantity and quality of counterfeits
has never been greater to me these
things are damn near one to one with
many buyers purposefully choosing the
steel I think it's pretty close to a
victimless crime over the real let's be
clear organized crime is involved so why
has the counterfeit Market exploded
and should the big Brands be worried
[Music]
my favorite pair oh that's so difficult
that's like asking a mother to choose
her favorite child right
Tallulah is a self-styled sneakerhead
like Millions around the world this pair
of Jordan fours I have they're called
classic greens they're from like 2006
and it was like the first shoot I was
like I need this in my life and she's
lucky enough to combine her passion with
her day job
we have the Dual Jordan one which was
like nearly six thousand pounds that's a
shoe that a lot of sneak heads will like
never even get to like hold in their
hand or see so that was a pretty crazy
moment
but Tallulah is not making or selling
sneakers her job is to sniff out the
fakes
the smile test is a part of the
authentication process that we do
as well this one
there's a strong toxic smell that would
not be a good sign for us
she works in this secret Warehouse
specially set up by eBay to stop the
endless flow of counterfeit products
onto its platform everything from
Handbags and watches to playing cards
and shoes
so counterfeit shoes is like a daily
occurrence that we see if a shoe has
just released you know that immediately
the people that make fakes are going to
be straight on it
the legal Global Athletic sneaker Market
is already worth more than 100 billion
dollars and is expected to keep growing
and when products of any kind are in
such high demand this often fuels a boom
in counterfeits
generally an increase in listed trade
overall leads to an increase in
illicitrade just because more trade is
more opportunity for enlisted trade and
usually is growing the market
Footwear has become the most seized
counterfeited product in the world
accounting for nearly a quarter of all
confiscated Goods
want to know if I wear my kicks 49 is
truly selling dead stocks eBay checks
eBay's authentication Warehouse is part
of a fight back by big Brands against
the growing epidemic of Black Market
Goods
my aim is to prevent any unauthentic
items from entering the retailing
Network we've so far authenticated over
one and a half million pairs of sneakers
through our facility it's a 120 increase
year over year
so what's behind this extraordinary boom
in counterfeit Goods
perhaps the biggest driver has been the
e-commerce Revolution for the last
decade e-commerce has been growing fast
in both the legal and black markets
between 2017 and 2019 56 of seizures of
counterfeit Goods within the European
Union
were linked to online sales
then came the pandemic when e-commerce
transactions and sales increased even
more rapidly making fake Goods of all
kinds even more accessible
consumers used to depend on bulk
shipments making their way from
wholesalers and middlemen to Street
Markets but today buying fakes feels a
lot like buying legal products
sites like Reddit mean you can order
bespoke Parcels directly from
counterfeiters with just a few clicks
the e-commerce completely revolutionized
the business of counterfeiting
the shipments used to be made generally
in large containers 20 foot or 40 foot
containers we regularly seized three
four thousand pieces since those days
shipments are sent out individually by
DHL by FedEx by China Post
thank you
counterfeiters are utilizing e-commerce
to further blur the line between the
legal and illegal retail markets when it
comes to selling fake sneakers some have
abandoned the old tricks of the trade
now counterfeiters often seek customer
satisfaction through transparency and
honesty
purposefully using the digital sphere to
advertise their counterfeiting prowess
online counterfeiters are incredibly
tech savvy online sales are their entire
business it's their bread and butter and
they need to stay ahead of the curve on
technology now how much would you be
prepared to Fork out for a pair of used
shoes
there's another 21st century Trend
common in legal retail which is driving
the Boom in counterfeit sneakers the
resale Market in America alone it is
worth an estimated 2 billion dollars a
year
at the top end investors are trading in
rare authentic sneakers which are sold
on for profits well now you can walk a
mile in Kanye West shoes the first pair
of Yeezys he ever wore are going up for
auction
this pair designed and worn by Kanye
West set a new auction record by selling
for 1.8 million dollars
people are investing in high value
sneakers they want something that they
can put on the shelf and maybe flip as
the value goes up it's a bit like fine
wine or an art collection this is a new
version of items that people have a
great deal of value in
Brands like Nike deliberately restrict
Supply on certain lines to build hype
and demand
this demand for rare and authentic
products has created a demand for high
quality fakes consumers are prepared to
pay good money for good fakes
so recently we've been seeing a lot of
counterfeits that they're getting a lot
of the good details of the shoot with
the value of sneakers at an all-time
high the counterfeit producers are
making sneakers kind of one-to-one
quality
the likes of eBay and stockx but
authentication tags on Sneakers but now
the counterfeiters are even copying
those tags some more credibly than
others
take a look look at the color look at
the color this was a little bit more
lime green this is just like a mint
green
online influences like this are found
across the web and just as influencers
have become an important way for
retailers to push legitimate products so
they have also become a significant
force in driving consumers towards
counterfeits to me these things are damn
near one to one I mean in my opinion
ones they have nailed
some of these influences have millions
of followers and their videos have had
millions of hits
they feed hungry consumers details about
the varying quality and costs of
counterfeits on offer they do look like
a really nice shoe even the fake ones I
can go online and buy a pair like this
close to the real thing I might get them
now you know this is a little
advertising for the real deal we have
some horribly fake ones like these some
argue these connoisseurs of counterfeit
are performing a much needed service for
consumers replicas or reps as they are
known are often simply more affordable
for buyers somebody shouldn't pay a
thousand dollars for a shoe that's
supposed to be from Nike and get it from
somewhere else I don't think that that's
right but if you're buying reps to wear
them because you can't afford or you
don't want to spend that kind of money
that doesn't bother me when it comes to
Consumers buying a replica that they
know to be a replica I think it's pretty
close to a victimless crime and the
consumer is not harmed sort of by
definition and arguably made better
better off because that person perhaps
couldn't afford uh or could only afford
a Great Lengths to buy the original
but promotion by influencers can only go
so far
to avoid being delisted from platforms
like YouTube influencers are careful not
to say where counterfeits can be bought
I didn't say where I got these from but
it is from a really reputable person and
name in the rep space
with the prolific Rise of influencers
and e-commerce demand for fake sneakers
is unlikely to subside anytime soon
so what about shutting down Supply
that's also tricky about 80 percent of
the market value of all fake Footwear
sees worldwide comes from the world's
largest manufacturing country China
biggest manufacturer for replicas in
China as a side note is actually Pew tan
China
the city of putian has become the global
capital of sneaker counterfeit
production
that's partly because putian also
produces the majority of the world's
genuine sneakers providing cover for
Black Market production
did you finish all your orders before
the Chinese New Year
thank you
illegal production has become more
closely intertwined with legal
production often within the same Factory
private detective Ted caveras has
witnessed this first hand when filming
undercover footage in factories
it's kind of the Urban Land scale that
you expect in China you drive Factory
Here Factor here factory here Factor
here
it's also doing like your Air Jordan how
many machines we have here 500.
in China counterfeits spawn copies of
counterfeits this is the original so
they took apart the sample right
if there's a criminal group making
counterfeits quite often they'll have
the number two or three in the hierarchy
I just learn the business and then set
up their own shop so one counterfeiting
group can give birth to three or four
competitors
although counterfeiters can seem more
like regular business people worried
about customer service and overheads
they are not always committing
victimless crimes
some counterfeit operators are also
involved in more dangerous and serious
criminal activities such as human
trafficking let's be clear organized
crime is involved I very rarely had a an
investigation that hasn't involved some
other type of crime we investigated a
group who had been exploiting Ethiopian
women who had been trafficked the
Ethiopian women were being locked in
rooms forced into making counterfeit
products at night they were forced onto
the streets into prostitution
the Chinese authorities have increased
efforts to crack down on Black Market
production and sales and there are ways
investigators can use technology to
catch the counterfeiters occasionally
they want people to know that their
reputable Sellers and that they're have
a thousand satisfied customers and the
platforms want this as well so there are
actually tracked records of sales on a
lot of these platforms showing how many
products the counterfeiter has sold this
is one tool we have that we can use
against the counterfeiters however the
sheer volume of production in China
means there is little hope of closing
down the supply line of fakes
it's a basic law of economics if there's
demand there will be Supply at a certain
point you can't really solve that all
you can do is kind of occasionally
nibble at the edges and knock off
certain uh suppliers and then another
supplier comes comes along and it's sort
of inevitable
it's not China's fault it's the demand
from overseas driving this business in
China so what we have to do is look at
who's buying it we have to control it
the customer too and do we do that by
education or by policing
there is no easy answer to curbing
consumer demand
for Brands wanting to slow down the
counterfeit Market there could be a
rough ride ahead in the end it's like
inflation
you know if you and I start literally
counterfeiting dollars or pounds who are
we really harming but in the aggregate
it starts to inflate away the value of
the dollar we all did that and so it's
the same kind of dynamic with Brands it
starts to inflate away the value of the
brand dilute the value of the brand
[Music]
hello I'm Tom standage Deputy editor at
The Economist if you'd like to learn
more about this topic click on the link
opposite thanks for watching and don't
forget to subscribe